Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Marvel has been making a bunch of fantastic
Four movie announcements lately, mostly about Pedro
Pascal, the rest of the cast.
But we also learned a little bit more about Galactus
during the movie, so we'll break it all down.
There is a lot of Marvel stuff
happening the last couple of weeks.
if you're brand new to the channel,
of course I'll be doing videos for everything.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We actually just got the
What if season two trailer video.
That'll be like the next big Marvel series after Loki.
They'll be coming later this year.
the real big news
you probably saw in your feeds this week, though,
in addition to all the what if season two stuff is that
now that the strikes are over,
Marvel is ramping up on all their movies
and shows across the board, not just Fantastic four.
ba ba. For the strikes.
They had a few actors for the fantastic
Four that seem like they were pretty locked down.
But for whatever reason, the strikes lasting so long.
people
getting cold feet about being in the Marvel movies
for like the next ten years because they're casting
like the main version of the Fantastic Four.
They're going to be in a bunch of movies
for the next ten years.
but with all the delays and the strikes,
just all the chaos behind the scenes
now, it sounds like some of their plans for actors
have changed a little bit.
So the cast has changed again.
And probably the biggest news is that apparently Pedro
Pascal
is going to be the new main version of Reed Richards,
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
What's going on?
Is nothing.
which was a total surprise for me.
I was actually kind of blown away.
I would have never considered him for the role
before this. there.
Even people.
Earlier this year, after the Last of US on HBO
and then The Mandalorian Season
three came out like one right after the other.
And people were like, Just you wait.
Pedro Pascal probably going to wind up
being Reed Richards in the Fantastic Four.
so, even if you were just joking about it
earlier this year, but you correctly guessed
it was going to be Pedro Pascal,
pat yourselves on the back Previously,
there have been reports that Jake Gyllenhaal
was going to be their new Reed Richards,
but he just turned down the offer, apparently.
Personally, I'm kind of glad that he did,
because can you imagine him showing up in Avengers
five Qing Dynasty with Tom Holland's Spider-Man
in that interaction?
it would be the most confused
you would ever have seen Spider-Man in any Marvel movie
before even seeing Tobey Maguire
and Andrew Garfield version and No Way Home.
all those Sinister six multiverse characters.
Like he were just completely blank staring at him.
Probably think that he was secretly Mysterio
having returned from the multiverse.
Like, What are you trying to pull here,
Jake Gyllenhaal would be much
better as the maker who's like the evil version
of Reed Richards from another alternate universe.
even though most of you were probably just assumed that
whoever they pick
for the new main version of Reed
Richards will also wind up playing the maker
in some multiverse movie like Secret Wars,
just because that is such a deep cut.
I do expect them to do the maker at some point
in some future Fantastic Four sequel movie.
in success.
Maybe he'll wind up being like the main villain
of the third Fantastic Four movie.
And whatever this new trilogy winds up being.
but I think Marvel and Disney's
reasoning for going with Pedro Pascal
is that he's like the safe bet for them.
Some of you probably expected them to make
a much weirder pick for their new main version of Reed
Richards.
But Pedro Pascal has been in that Disney ecosystem
for a long time now through The Mandalorian.
if you think about it, there's supposed to already
be a family of the Fantastic Four is a family,
so to speak, when the movie picks up in Pedro
Pascal is mostly known recently
for his dad roles like both in The Mandalorian
with Grogu in The Last of US
with Ellie In fact, Matt Shakman from Wandavision
is still directing the movie.
They've been doing pre-production during the strikes
because they've been able to do that.
They just haven't been able to film with actors
or actually write the movie itself.
during the strikes, they've been doing everything else
that goes into actually making a movie,
like doing all the concept art,
basically building the world out.
he literally just released a preview video
talking about the actual movie.
You know, it's funny that we have these characters
that you discover when you're a kid
and they just stick with you.
Godzilla was one of them,
and the Fantastic Four was another.
I think I love the space
race, Kennedy era optimism of that world,
the idea that we can solve all of our problems,
that we can through
the right heart and the right mind
and the right technology to conquer any problem.
You know, it's different in so many ways
because they are a true family, not a family
you find along the way, like the X-Men or The Avengers,
but true family with all the messiness of a family
like on Monarch, you know, with all the love
and the hurt and the complexity of that.
And also they approach things
with a sort of an optimist take and scientific approach
that is very different from these other
Marvel characters that I absolutely love.
But how they solve problems is unique,
and I'm excited about it as well.
And I hope folks like it when we put it out.
you kind of get the vibe of the movie
just in general, just him talking about it.
But Pedro Pascal had just hit a couple of massive home
runs the past couple of years
with The Last of US on HBO.
He's blowing it up all over the place.
Kevin Feige the Marvel and Disney people probably
just felt like he was a very, very safe bet for them.
like we know he can act.
We already have a contract with him for this upcoming
Mandalorian season
for a serious Season two, the Thrawn movie
that's going to spin out of that.
So, like,
we're already doing a bunch of stuff with him,
so why don't we just add like a page to his contract
for all this fantastic four stuff?
talk about Pedro Pascal into the Pascal verse.
this does make me feel like he is probably never going
to take his helmet off on The Mandalorian again.
he's got like three other movies
that he's working on right now.
so do not be surprised
if his Mandalorian Season four episodes
are just in voiceover with him
not taking the helmet off.
if you haven't seen much of his live action
acting The Last of US
is probably the best go to, at least at first Narcos.
Also a pretty good example of like a slightly
more serious version of that character.
most of his Mandalorian stuff is just voiceover.
I think that his version of Reed Richards
would be somewhere between like John Krasinski's
more serious version of the character
a little Down to Earth and Young Griffin's version
of the character who is way more comic book,
just way lighter in tone in general.
Personally,
I found John Krasinski, his version of the character
a little more chill than the Miles Teller
version of Reed Richards.
Most consider him to be like the most hardcore
dark series version of the character
because that Fantastic Four movie is like the darkest,
most hardcore Fantastic Four movie just in general,
based on the rest of this new MCU Fantastic
Four movie cast, I think Marvel is going for something
slightly lighter in tone than that, but not as wacky
as the classic Chris Evans Fantastic Four.
like. The way that Matt Shakman talks about it.
It's not going to be all dark and serious, but it won't
be quite as wacky as the classic Fantastic Four.
as far as we know, the rest of the Fantastic
Four cast as of this week,
hopefully this doesn't change
is still Vanessa Kirby as Sue Storm.
she was literally just asked about this
while she was promoting the Napoleon movie
and is very clearly trying to avoid talking about it.
It's kind of funny.
This memorial is going to announce you
in Fantastic Four.
I didn't know you could us.
Is that one of
the project that's you're excited to be joining?
I would be very honored to join.
you could tell she's been practicing on
not answering these questions recently, like,
you're going to get a bunch of questions
about this. Fantastic for stuff.
So do not reveal anything.
I already did a video about her Sue Storm back when she
was first references the character early this year.
We've known about her for a while.
she was supposedly like one of the first actors
that they locked down.
one of the big changes with this new MCU Fantastic
Four solo movie, though, is that supposedly
she'll become a much bigger character
than she's been in previous versions.
Like previously, she was more of a side character.
personally, I'm hoping that she plays a more hardcore,
weird, unhinged version of the character.
Like most of Vanessa Kirby's
roles in her live action movies.
Like if you haven't seen the Napoleon Movie,
it like it's just coming out in the next week.
She's fantastic in that
the like imagine her character in all the Mission
Impossible movies that she's been in.
just that weird, unhinged energy just cannot wait
to see that inside an MCU Fantastic Four movie.
supposedly
Ebon Mosbacher out from The Punisher in the Bear
on Ethics is going to be the new Ben Grimm thing.
he was great during the Punisher series as micro.
This basically confirms he won't be back in Daredevil
born again as that version of micro.
But this is fine like this is a huge upgrade for him
being in Fantastic Four.
I think that his Ben Grimm
is going to feel a little closer to the kind of energy
that you see from his character on the Bear,
like he's a very nice character,
but almost every other word that comes out of his mouth
is a curse word.
in just like Vanessa Kirby,
he has this weird, unhinged kind of crazy energy to him
during the Punisher, he was always getting pushed
around by Frank Castle, the other characters.
And that's not really the way the thing
would be reacting to that kind of pressure around him.
Like his whole catchphrase is it's clobbering time.
He would much rather clobber
his problems in the people giving in grief
reportedly their version of Johnny Storm Human Torch.
As Amy posting
this video is still Joseph Quinn from Stranger Things.
Most of you remember him as Eddie Munson.
He was great during that series.
in I've talked about the villains before,
but reportedly the main villain of the movie
will be a much more comic book
accurate version of Galactus no more floaty
cloud Galactus there was a version, the character
they almost wound up using in Thor, Love and Thunder.
I'm so happy that they wound up deleting that scene.
Like you can clearly tell that it was going to be Jane
Foster Thor fighting a version of Galactus.
And that's not the way
you want to introduce the character to the MCU.
If you want people to take the character seriously,
for most of this year,
it was supposed to be Antonio Banderas
playing the character like Puss in Boots Galactus.
But now it looks like Javier Bardem
might wind up playing their Galactus.
We'll see.
Either way, they're not too different in terms
of what you expect from them.
But Javier Bardem is just more known
for his more hardcore villainous roles.
So you think if Marvel wants a more hardcore, serious
Galactus Javier Bardem would be the one to go with.
both of them are great actors, though.
and speaking of Galactus, the next big question,
What about Silver Surfer?
Apparently, Silver Surfer is not supposed to be
in this first new Fantastic Four movie,
or at least is a big character.
They're actually supposed to be using tear
acts as his Herald.
he was one of the subsequent heralds after Galactus
first debuted in the Fantastic Four comics,
like when he debuted for the first time,
Silver Surfer was his Herald.
But then eventually Tear Acts was introduced
as a subsequent Herald.
this is also one of the reasons
why they're doing Galactus in the first new MCU
Fantastic Four movie,
because he wasn't the first Fantastic Four villain,
but he was one of their very,
very early villains in their very first comic book run.
Marvel is going super cosmic heading into Avengers
five.
In Avengers six Secret Wars.
Galactus is like one of the biggest, metaphorically
and literally
cosmic characters from the comics
they have not done yet in the new MCU movies.
it almost seems like doing the Celestials
in the Eternals movie was sort of like a test
run for them pulling up more comic book
accurate version of Galactus off
like, okay, here these super weird, super cosmic,
super powerful beings with a bunch of lore behind them.
this way different
from anything we've done in the MCU so far.
Maybe we could actually do a version of Galactus
without everybody laughing at him.
there've been all kinds of rumors
about what the actual plot of the movie is going to be,
how they're going to explain where the Fantastic Four
come from, how they explain their existence in the MCU.
But Matt Shakman,
the director, said that most people have
absolutely no idea, like their approach to the movie
is going to be so different
from the previous Fantastic Four movies
that a lot of people just will be totally blown away
and I think the idea is they're going to say
that they actually do come from another universe.
And that's why none of the MCU characters either know
about them or have mentioned them up to this point.
most of you also probably realize that Kevin Feige
wants to sort of set up the Fantastic Four,
particularly Reed Richards in Sue
Storm is big pillars in the MCU the way that Iron Man,
Captain America, Doctor Strange Spider-Man,
those are the characters have been in the past,
The X-Men will be like big pillars too,
but we haven't seen a lot of them show up yet.
That won't happen till little bit later,
but you can kind of see with this whole Marvel
soft reboot they're doing in secret wars in them
pivoting towards X-Men fantastic force up
how some of those characters
will become like the new central figures
next to people like Spider-Man.
The next ten years of Marvel.
for the most part, I think people are ready for them
to do a really hardcore X-Men saga
like Marvel, Phase seven, eight, nine,
whatever that winds up being after Secret Wars
Speaking of which, supposedly we're going to get
the X-Men 97 episodes at some point early next year.
Like we just got the what if season two trailer video.
I think that's meant to sort of tee up like their next
big saga of animation with the X-Men stuff
I literally just did a video for that,
so I'll link it at the end of this.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up too,
but if you have any big questions about fantastic Four
just in general, just write them below in the comments.
And as we get more
announcements, I'll do more videos about the movie.
there's been all kinds of reports
about them pivoting away from the Kang character
and pivoting towards Doctor Doom.
I'll do a video about that
sometime in the next couple of days to I'm
still working on a brand new Loki Season three video
that should be up in the next couple of days.
My next big video will be for Invincible Season
2 Episode 3
Make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
there's also a brand new Godzilla Monarch series.
The first couple of episodes will be up later tonight.
I'll try to do a video for that sometime soon too.
Click here for my brand new
What If Season two trailer video and Easter Eggs
and click here for that brand new Spider-Man
Madame Web trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!